yes the story of tuberculosis is a
dramatic one tuberculosis is older than
history it's never given civilized man
peace
no one artist a statesman rich or poor
young or old is immune to it once it was
a hopeless case but now thanks to our
knowledge it can be brought under
control now let me tell you about it
tuberculosis is caused by a germ so
small thousands could pass through
pinholes without clarity we know exactly
what it looks like the tubercle bacillus
is a living plant it grows and
reproduces it dies quickly in boiling
water or sunshine but thrives in the
human body how does the germ get into
the body
well careless people who have the
disease may spit on the floor a sidewalk
mixed to the dust the germs may be blown
about and breathed by others it's child
for example may carry the germs on the
lollipop to her mouth or germs may be
left on any article that touches the
lips the next person who puts one of
these articles into his mouth gives the
germs a chance to get into his body but
far more important is the danger of
direct contact especially lip contact
the one who has the disease was one who
hasn't how can our little friend John
for example escape getting into his
lungs some of the tuberculosis germs of
his Aunt Alice who has been visiting she
loves him dearly
but doesn't seem to realize that what
she calls her chronic bronchitis is
really tuberculosis now let us suppose
that some of the germs
and Alice's lungs have actually made
their way into Johnson they have gained
a foothold here in the lung substance
what happens then we have focused a
powerful microscope on the spot and here
we see the germs attached to the lung
substance John is now infected soon the
germs increase in number and begin to
spread but see the cells of the body
seem to be waking up they are jailing
them in a tight little capsule called a
to become it's a battle royale now but
this time the body wins lucky John of
course these are just diagrams but that
is about what happens there you see the
first tubercle eventually a gritty
substance called calcium takes the place
of the destroyed lung substance and the
little shell becomes hard and stony in
fact it is this gritty material that
casts its shadow on the x-ray film here
is an x-ray picture of such a first to
become the disease in this case gets no
further than that first tubercle except
that some germs may escape to the nearby
lymph glands or nodes lymph glands serve
as filters stopping germs from spreading
over the body here they are stopped the
lymph glands may suffer some damage but
this is repaired just as in the lungs
substance these to show on the x-ray
film no two cases of tuberculosis are
exactly alike but what we have seen
probably happens very commonly many many
persons are reflected his children but
never know it and then on the worse for
it but on with the story
John has grown he's the senior in high
school now and he's been infected again
though he doesn't know it perhaps his
aunt who has come to live with the
family because John had already been
infected the cells of his bar
have been stimulated or sensitized to
the further attacks of these
tuberculosis germs now in their
eagerness to surround the germs and
protect the body from them the cells
often destroy themselves thus giving the
germs a chance to spread and once they
get started the germs soon destroy
tissue and do real damage until they are
checked besides John was a bit careless
he used up too much of his energy hard
work at school
strenuous athletics out late at night
let's look again at John's lung yes
the original tubercle is still there
firm and hard and the healed lymph nodes
but look there's a bit of trouble here
nothing to get excited about you say yet
that is the real beginning of serious
tuberculosis John has no symptoms he
probably feels physically well he
wouldn't think of going to a doctor a
dark tragedy is staring John in the face
but lucky John the enemy was discovered
how in the up-to-date high school he
attended that ritalin test was offered
to all students this test is simple and
harmless well here is John at the head
of the line a few drops of a liquid
called
tuberculin is injected into the skin
hurt well yes
about like a mosquito bite and a lot
less harmful than many a mosquito bite
two days later the test is read if the
spot is raised and reddened it is called
positive what does that mean only that
at some time tuberculosis germs have
entered the body in this school 30% of
the children were positive so these were
x-rayed to see if the germs were doing
any damage John was one of them no need
to x-ray the others because
without infection there can be no
tuberculosis when Jones family doctor
had looked at their developed film this
is what he saw the old shadows scarcely
visible and here in the upper part of
the right lung some suspicious shadows
not very serious John spent a short time
in bed and then he went back to school
but what bother the doctor was where did
John get his infection and his re
infection he knew that every case comes
from another
so naturally he sent for John's parents
I just wanted to make sure miss brown
that John did not get his infection at
home your lungs are absolutely all right
and so mr. Brown and Jean showed only a
positive tuberculin test that doctor my
sister Alice has come to live with us
again she cost them all by all means ask
you to come to see me to make a long
story short the doctor found that Aunt
Alice at an old chronic tuberculosis
they were typical bacilli in Rasputin's
see this cavity in the lung from it
comes a steady stream of germs yet she
didn't feel sick enough to complain
there are many such people for John's
sake she consented to go to the
sanatorium
now suppose we pick up the story where
we left it with John just the little
inflammation here with rest in bed the
little true becomes which cast these
shadows hardened and quickly stopped the
spread of the disease supposes had not
been discovered but then well it
probably would have spread
what's this spot it is being hollowed
out now it is a cavity inside the germs
a growing size and many of them escape
into the air passages and a coughed up a
veritable factory of germs is such a
cavity serious for the patient and
dangerous to all those with whom he
comes in close contact it takes years of
rest in bed to heal it and sometimes
never heals but goes on to death but I
am happy to say that even this serious
condition is not hopeless today well
there is a way of collapsing a diseased
lung let me show you how that is done it
requires a simple operation called
pneumothorax which means putting air
into the chest
since the lung is soft it is easily
collapsed as one would squeeze a sponge
the cavity is closed and that stops the
manufacture of germs it rests the lung
and gives it a chance to heal the cough
stops the fever goes down and best of
all no more germs are spit up that is
exactly the way John's Aunt Alice was
treated of course the air gradually
leaks out but it is an easy matter to
put in more air every two weeks or so
until the lung has healed completely
then gradually the lung is allowed to
re-expand pneumothorax is a lifesaver
for thousands I am sure that you know
appreciate that the earlier tuberculosis
is discovered the more certain is
secure delayers utterly dangerous it is
costly but doctor what is the answer to
this problem
surely once they get tuberculosis the
money is well spent in the cure
yes but money well suspended prevention
will make EUR unnecessary we must beat
our silent enemy to it and strike him
down before he strikes us every young
person from 15 to 25 years ought to have
the benefit of the tuberculin test and
the x-ray and someday I hope that we
shall make a routine practice of testing
every child from babyhood with
tubercular to spot the enemy at its
first shadow I am confident you young
people will see the victorious end of
this struggle